er steht immer noch in Abu Dhabi der
regierungsflieger der Außenministerin
schon gestern war der Weiterflug
gescheitert heute Nacht versucht Nummer
2 und auch der war schnell vorbei
wir sind gerade im Kreise tatsächlich
leider das gleiche Problem was wir
gestern abend wieder passiert wie
gestern schon ließen sich nach dem Start
die Landeklappen nicht mehr einfahren
wie gestern schon musste tonnenweise
Kerosin abgelassen werden wie gestern
schon landete der Flieger so von Gewicht
befreit gleich wieder in Abu Dhabi
tut mir leid zweimal passiert ist
ich mache das schon ein paar Jahre aber
sowas auch in der Geschichte der
Flugbereitschaft noch nicht passiert die
jüngere Geschichte der Flugbereitschaft
ist eine Geschichte voller Pannen 2018
Kanzlerin Merkel muss auf dem Weg zum
G20-Treffen nach Argentinien Umdrehen
der Funkfeld aus die Elektronik spinnt
Merkel fliegt ein Linie und verpasst den
ersten Gipfeltag ebenfalls 2018 Olaf
Scholz damals Finanzminister strandet in
Indonesien Ratten hatten einige
Elektrokabel angefressen
2019 Entwicklungsminister Gerd Müller
bleibt in Sambia wegen technischer
Probleme hängen
made in Germany hat einen erheblichen
Schaden genommen in Afrika das wird
natürlich überall berichtet
Außenminister Heiko Maas hat 2019
innerhalb von drei Monaten gleich
dreimal Pech mit den regierungsfliegern
manchmal könnte man annehmen dass wir
von mehr pannengebäudet sind als ich sag
mal vergleichbare Airlines dem ist mit
nicht so wir sind auf dem technischen
Niveau einer renommierten Airline
Außenministerin bärburg hat ihre Reise
in die Pazifik Region inzwischen
abgesagt und fliegt heute Linie zurück
nach Berlin der regierungsflieger in Abu
Dhabi eh schon kurz vor Ende seines
Dienstes wird mit sofortiger Wirkung
ausgemustert
und die Außenministerin begleitet hat
man Kollege Daniel pontzen aus dem
Hauptstadtstudio noch ist er in Abu
Dhabi wo die Regierungsmaschine ja
gestrandet ist hallo Daniel also die
Reise nach Neuseeland Australien und
Fidschi die fährt jetzt erstmal komplett
aus welche politischen Folgen hat das
ja hallo also so direkte unmittelbare
konkrete politische Folgen hat das nicht
unter anderem auch deswegen weil manches
was für die Reise geplant war und
trotzdem stattfindet auch ohne
Ministerin zum Beispiel eine
botschaftseröffnung auf den
Fidschi-Inseln die wird dann auch ohne
Ministerin eröffnet da kann die Arbeit
also wie vorgesehen beginnen zum anderen
werden auch Kulturgüter zurückgegeben
wie es geplant war auch das ohne
Ministerin aber das zentrale politische
Signal das von dieser Reise ausgehen
sollte das bleibt natürlich jetzt
erstmal ungesendet die Ministerin hat
kurz vor ihrer Rückreise noch mal betont
dass die Indopazifik Region die
Weltordnung des 21 jahrhunderts
entscheiden prägen werde und deswegen
sei der Austausch mit den Partnern in
dieser Region so zentral mit den
wertepartnern wie sie sie nannte die
Länder in die sie wollte Australien
Neuseeland und die fidge-inseln die
Reise war ohnehin relativ spät geplant
weil die Außenministerin noch die China
Strategie der Bundesregierung abwarten
wollte die ist ja vor kurzem
veröffentlicht worden nun also fällt die
ganze erstmal flach aber sie will das
ganze nachholen in Kürze oder ob es noch
länger dauert steht noch nicht fest sie
hatten steht sehr dichten dichten
Terminplan das ganze hat immer einen
großen planerischen Vorlauf das heißt da
kann man so eine Reise von einer Woche
länger nicht so einfach reinquetschen
aber was natürlich unabhängig davon
bleibt ist dass das Bild das jetzt in
die Welt gesendet wurde mit dieser
erneuten doppelpanne muss man ja sagen
natürlich alles andere als ein positives
ist Einschätzung von Daniel pontzen live
aus Abu Dhabi vielen Dank und guten
Heimflug